Mark I wanna we spent a lot of time in
the last segment we're talking about the
the history of this party and the issue
of race and a lot of America doesn't
know this you even rightly pointed out a
lot of members of Congress you know
Republicans constantly on defense being
accused of being racist Etc ignoring
even Joe Biden's history of associating
you know with the likes of Robert Byrd
but
it you also you're interweaving within
this book where America is today and at
one point you actually say in America
Freedom Free Speech academic freedom are
shrinking the police state is growing as
is monitoring and spying on citizens the
government is Banning and regulating
more and more household products crime
is out of control on our streets public
transportation in schools and while
police budgets are slashed and
prosecutors caught on violent criminals
and our borders are wide open and you
talk about the Democrat Party seeking to
control our governmental institutions uh
delegitimize eviscerate the Constitution
abusing the rule of law by targeting
political opponents for harassment
in so many ways it's relevant to
everything that you and I and and others
there's not a lot of us discuss every
single day but it really you tie
together the history of this and where
it all came from
this battle if you want to call it the
Deep State whatever you want to call it
you cannot read this book and not come
away with the conclusion this battle has
been going on for the heart and soul of
this country for a long time and I'd
argue right now it's probably worse than
it's ever been at least in my lifetime
well you're 100 right but what don't we
ever say
who's responsible for this and we'll
talk about Biden we'll talk about this
one we'll talk about that one oh this is
horrendous what's happening Congress
excuse me
there's a reason these things are
happening
the Democrat Party and its surrogates
are doing this to our country
they're doing this to our country
intentionally you actually write in in
chapter four in the book
talking about these radicals and how
they appeal to the masses by focusing on
the paradise they promise in the future
if only every individual surrenders
their Free Will impart or in whole to a
small cabal of activists revolutionaries
uh ultimately autocratic masterminds who
claim to speak and represent the people
now what's amazing to me about this
because this is the exact battle we're
now engaged in in this country this is
what new green dealism is you know
guaranteed government wage guaranteed
job guaranteed Health Care you know
Pre-K free college you know everything's
free free free
my first question is the same people
these are the same people that destroyed
our Public School System we spend more
per capita with the worst results these
are the same people that have brought
Social Security and Medicare to the
brink of bankruptcy these are the same
people that gave us Obamacare with the
false promise you keep your doctor you
keep your plan and the average family
saves twenty five hundred dollars a year
but here's my point to you and I I and I
want you to weigh in on this is that I
don't care what name it's given climate
alarmism new green deolism socialism I
don't care what manifestation it takes
on and and I did a whole chapter about
this in my last book but you go into the
history of this
and it always ends the same way these
lofty promises that are unfulfilled you
end up with more poverty than you began
with and then you calculate at the end
of this this ridiculous experiment how
much of your freedom you gave up in the
name of false security but yet it's
appealing to people that they'll Empower
one group their government to take one
group of people's wealth that they pay
taxes on even and they will redistribute
it to another group of people that's the
Utopia they always sell and a better
life that they promise that never never
ever is fulfilled but yet it gets you
know repeated throughout history doesn't
it
yes it does and uh you talk about
climate change this movement was
invented in the 1970s by European
marxists I explain it they met it's the
degrowth movement
they hate capitalism they hate mankind
they hate prosperity
uh they're marxists and they want to
redistribute wealth and they think
particularly the United States the
industrialized country are stealing all
these minerals and so forth uh from the
third world now nobody's stealing
anything from anybody the third world
would the participate in capitalism they
could make maximum use perhaps and those
minerals as well we're a wealthy country
not because we steal things because we
invent things because we're a relatively
free country that follows
entrepreneurship and capitalism that's
why our wealthy country but that doesn't
work with the oppressor oppressed model
now as for the rest of it this is where
we get to the propaganda line
everything is done in the name of the
people everything is done as some kind
of altruistic righteous Act
and this is how they wrap it up uh this
is how Mao so young wrapped it up and he
killed 60 million people this is how all
of these genocidal maniacs and uh not
yet genocidal Maniacs but radicals do it
why they lie lying is the coin of the
realm why because Marxism is an
impossibility
socialism is an impossibility the green
New Deal or whatever they want to call
climate change is camouflage for
socialism redistribution of wealth the
destruction of prosperity and growth
that's exactly what it is they can talk
about electric cars Joe Biden doesn't
know electricity from gasoline if it's
life dependent on it doesn't matter it's
an ideology and they think they've come
across a nomenclature in a position
talking as you as you project onto them
in ways that are very very lofty people
can't really have a problem with it
let's take two other words real quickly
equality and Equity what does that mean
what does it mean we are free people
we're individuals
some do better than others some are
smarter than others some are physically
better than others some work harder than
others some have more luck than others
what does equality mean for the founders
of many quality under the law whomever
you are you should be treated justly
under the law I call this the new civil
rights Marxism
if you don't buy off on Marxism and
they've taken over the entire Civil
Rights Movement which is now an economic
movement if you don't agree to the
destruction of our economy you don't if
you don't agree to taking wealth from
those who create it and giving it to
those who don't in other words Democrats
if you don't agree to those things then
obviously you're a bigot you're a racist
you're a white supremacist and uh in
fact it's just another
outrageously clever way for the
Democrats to push their hate America
agenda
all right we'll take a break this book
right here the Democrat Party hates
America the great one Mark Levin will
have more mark on the other side you can
get the book hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else